Magnus epatha happy new doesn't
restrictions on song and so for that
bothered us you okay
a young double sorry daddy finger day
energy has been at the heart of the
European project since its foundation
and it still is today more than ever
energy is what binds us beyond borders
in Europe we import more than half of
our energy our energy markets remain
fragmented and so our companies pay much
more for energy than their international
competitors we are wasting far too much
energy climate change is putting our
planets future at risk and jeopardizing
the future of our children we are losing
our competitive edge in key energy
technologies to make our energy more
secure sustainable and affordable we
need a new era of cooperation we need
solidarity
we need a European energy union which is
fit for the future this means greater
security of supply we must reduce our
dependence on import and find new
external energy sources suppliers and
rules we also need to build new
electricity and gas connectors across
national borders and speak with one
voice when negotiating with our
international partners
this also means a strong sustainable
climate friendly economy that will drive
the creation of jobs an escape for the
future to this end we will deliver tight
the co2 a standard for makers in a
gradual transformation of the entire
transport system we will also improve
our carbon market and become the world
leader in the global energy
last and at least this means affordable
energy for all our citizens we will
reform wholesale and retail energy
markets to increase competition and
drive down consumer prices we will
introduce a range of new measures of
energy efficiency for buildings and the
transport sector and ultimately engage
consumers into managing and even
generating their own electricity this
together will be milestones in putting a
strong energy Union in motion this will
not be and will require trust respect
and cooperation but we owe it to the 500
million citizens of Europe and to our
future generations